did you did you think like in your mind
were you thinking where man better enjoy
this process cuz this shit's coming to
an end quick this doesn't last that long
of a time where you were like no I'm
going for the right this is going to
last forever what what when you were in
it and I'm talking when you're peing
yeah well that was the hardest part is
peaking that that was really really the
hardest thing there there was a you know
cuz it's like oh God it was a whole
other world that I wasn't prepared for I
don't think anybody who gets to the that
level of Fame you're never prepared for
it and uh you know everything turns on
its head nothing nothing you ever
thought uh remains how how crazy was it
like for you know uh you you'll in life
they say there's levels right hey you
you're making six I'm finally making six
figures I'm 26 years old oh wow you walk
into a room real estate office and other
guy's making 1.2 million oh my goodness
I will never make you make 1.2 million
one walk into room guy just clothes a
$10 million cash oh 10 million walking
100 million oh my God walking Real
Estate Mogul $3 billion it's like then
there is the one right because that's a
different you know you're famous in a
small little Club then you're famous at
your state then you're famous in a
region then you're famous in a country
then you're famous in the world then
you're number one in the world you went
to number one it's not like you know you
were not one of you know how they say
she's one of the great ones she's one of
the No No you went to the Pinnacle right
yeah I was the highest
paid person ever on television that's
crazy to think I I made a million
dollars a week a million a week back way
back in the in the in in the '90s
1990s when when when you got to that
level I guess what I'm trying to say is
when you got to the level of the number
one did you all of a sudden be be like
man I didn't know why am I creating new
enemies when new people are getting
pissed were older people being woken up
because they were jealous and envious of
how you know where you went and how is
she she's not not better than me how can
she be there I did you start seeing that
other people targeting you or no you
were free you were flying you were
having a blast nobody was getting a way
of your success I was always on a we
weird uh W wavelength of my own you know
but yeah I did start seeing that I
started seeing Oh my God they've
completely isolated me and I don't have
anybody to talk to I don't trust nobody
around me that's and things are
disappearing out of my house
you know is weird oh wow and it was like
being a prisoner like when I think of
those uh I mean I don't mean to compare
myself to that but you know when them
when those girls got held in that house
for 10 years in I can't
remember yeah it was kind of like that
and you couldn't say anything because
they were all hooked up together like
Kanye says you know your trainer was all
hooked up and they were all hooked up
together and their job was to control
you and only you know make sure you only
saw the things that were beneficial to
them that you only knew of the things
that were beneficial to them and by
beneficial I mean that their pay would
increase who did you trust at that time
like nobody literally nobody I I trusted
nobody wait a minute no family no agents
no uhow I had already my family had
imploded by that time and we didn't
speak for many years so I didn't have
any allies really that's a tough and I
was like I'm going to have to get myself
out of this and how am I going to do it
and I did do it but you know I had all
these plans that I was going to uh
change my identity and disappear CU I I
thought they're going to kill me so but
I want to say that when it first
happened the thing that was so great CU
I always admired Elvis you know love
Elvis and uh part of my fantasy of
getting famous and Rich and all that was
I was going to want to be like Elvis you
know where you would like really I love
that show the millionaire too where
you'd go and help people MH cuz you were
in finally in a position to put your
beliefs into practice and you could
actually help people and so that was uh
a a a large part of what carried me
through in the beginning because I was
like oh man I'm going to be able to do
this I'm going to be able to start uh
these organizations and my thing was
about children you know Abus children
and and so I did did so much of that and
I I did a lot for uh you know various
things like that and things that were
important to me I could underwrite and
that was really that was just a great
feeling because I was like uh that's
what you're doing it for you know you
know years ago and also I love to I love
to fund
lawsuits that was the hugest coolest
part of the whole deal literally yeah
for real why because I just was on this
thing for justice you know and I was
like oh hell yeah I'll pay for that
lawsuit what type of lawsuits do you God
I took so I did a lot of lawsuits I did
one lawsuit before I was even famous
that went to the Supreme Court and we
won I didn't find that out for 15 years
that we had won but what was the case it
it was about uh nonprofit
organizations and that's a whole other
story but um yeah uh whether can use the
word revolution or reform mhm so that
that's a whole long thing ran when when
you're
uh but like mostly women who' been
slighted in work and especially like for
the uh hostile work environment W I love
that one I love funding lawsuits love
yeah it was a blast that's pretty
interesting I still do I funded one on
on a an Indian reservation too to be
able to uh legalize their ability to
grow uh
cannabis and we won that right you know
I just wanted to
be I just wanted to uh I wanted to make
God proud of me you know that was what I
really wanted CU I was like yeah you
know store up your Treasures in Heaven
you know since what age three since
three yeah what happened at
three um
I
just I had like a big Spiritual
Awakening I I don't know if you call it
Awakening but an experience at three
that like set my tone for the rest of my
life that I've never gone astray from
about just doing you know I I wrote
about it in a book I wrote a book called
Rose
Anarchy and uh I talk about my personal
relationship with God in that book and
how God was my uh you know all kids have
a an imaginary friend when and mine was
God but it really was and I would always
talk to God and uh and uh he would
answer and everything but in the book I
say that I'd
say why don't you fix things I'd say uh
all you have to do is move one of your
fingers and you could solve all the
world's problems and that God answers me
goes I don't have fingers Roseanne you
do and uh he said and you should you
should really be glad that I gave you
the opposable thumb so it can really
help you to do do things in the world
and uh you know those are the kind of
conversations I had but I grew up in an
apartment house with Holocaust survivors
in Salt Lake City Utah that my
grandparents had sponsored over from
camps and uh
so I heard horror stories from the age
of you know before I could
even probably walk and uh and at age
three I just felt a presence and it told
me that I was going to live and that I
was going to
tell and uh you know I did and I I did
how how chaotic was your life at three
well it's terribly chaotic in in what
way well you know uh every Friday night
these people would come to my grandma's
house and we'd have Shabbat dinner and
um my Grandma had a window sill and I
would get up there and entertain because
you know I was a big show off and um my
family lied to me and told me I was
better than Shirley Temple and I really
believed them till I was about 12 and
then I was so angry when I found out
that they were Liars but uh well they
were partially true though I mean you
were number one you became number one
think about it yeah I guess yeah but I I
really thought I was doing the goodship
lollipop song and dance better than
Shirley but yeah but I did get him to
laugh and I got him to uh applaud and I
I just was turned on by that that I
could take some miserable people and
make them happy for a little while and
that made me feel so strong and so good
and that is what I do but uh also shake
them up a little little bit you know to
go hey wait a minute maybe it's not the
way you look at it maybe it's something
else and I love doing that I I've loved
doing that with comedy always and uh you
know but I uh you know they would tell
stories about what they'd live through
and they um were also watching the ikan
trial on tv and they'd make me watch it
you know and oh God the horror the
horror pictures and stuff yeah and then
they'd talk about what they had been
through and I was like I thought that we
lived that way still I thought it was
the Warsaw Ghetto in there I thought we
were still there and uh you know it was
a lot of trauma and I I grew up with a
lot of trauma and my family uh the men
in my family they were kind of working
class and my dad was a football player
and they were kind of
violent you
know but uh and the women were violent
too you know you you know you you had to
really be funny to keep from getting hit
in my family had to be funny to keep
from getting hit yeah if you made them
laugh then they wouldn't hit you that's
a pretty high standard for comedy what a
tough what a tough rule you better that
joke better be good they're laughing
they're not hitting yeah so I I kind of
learned to tell jokes and my dad was
real funny too he wanted to be a comic
he kind of made me one and uh so I
always had comedy and uh
and uh I loved it because I thought oh
boy that's the only place you can tell
the truth about anything and I loved
that in history the the comic the fool
the uh Jester could go was the one that
once a year could go into the king and
tell him tell jokes about the king to
his face and he'd have to laugh because
all the people were watching and that
was what made him beloved to the people
cuz he had a sense of humor about
himself like Don Rickles would go and
Reagan and just crap on everybody yeah
that was what a job what' you do today I
just made fun of the president so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here